we're on hold so we can get all of the t
this is the new hampshire house special
committee on redistricting today is
november 3rd we have a work session
scheduled today and tomorrow the purpose
of these work sessions is to go through
proposed maps by committee members and
have maps to go to
public input sessions next week
next week we will have public input
sessions in reps hall they will be
tuesday the 9th commencing at 10 am
and wednesday the 10th commencing at 5
p.m
today we're going to review
the county commissioner submissions for
hb 54
and four state rep maps for hb 50 that
would be merrimack
belknap rockingham and coast
tomorrow we will be addressing the
remaining six
counties for state reps
and the congressional district
now that's a lot of maps i'm going to
ask committee members to work primarily
off the paper copies that you have been
provided so we know we're all looking at
the same thing
if you have your computer on that's fine
but for purposes of map discussion let's
stay with what you've got
let's go through the crib sheets that i
have prepared
or lindsay
in staff has prepared at great help
you should all have a sheet that looks
like this
this
corresponds to the stack of maps that
are underneath it and the number on the
left of that sheet you will find
at the bottom of the first page of the
set of maps
so
initial as you can see we don't go quite
consecutively because we sort of went
through this and had to pull some
because they either were not accurate or
not applicable to today's maps but the
numbering is correct for you to follow
so for example number one
is a coast county commissioner map
and for each map you should have a
printout
and then the program
calculation for numbers
you should also have a sheet that looks
like this
and this is an attempt
to give you
an order
which corresponds with the map numbers
so we're going to discuss commissioners
first
and we're going to start with bellnap
and so that means we're going to be
going to map number four in your pile
and then because of the way the
commissioner files were sent over you're
going to pull number 7
because there are 10 commissioner maps
in there and we will go through those
as compared to the belknap coast and
merrimack so i have
two commissioner maps of middles
for belknap
coast and merrimack
i have only received
one commissioner submission for the
remaining
seven counties
so one of the purposes of this is to go
through so if somebody wants to do
another map or we think something needs
to happen we have the chance to do it
okay
all right
let's start
yes representative lane
thank you um i think you mentioned
before about availability on the website
we all learned that
the website's not
working is it going to be corrected
before next week because members of the
public can't access and don't have
copies of these maps so
what
the website was apparently updated
i suspect over the weekend because
monday i got an email that said there's
a new website by the time i took a look
at it at monday night i went to the
redistricting website which now sort of
corresponds with the website format that
the senate has been using in general for
a little while and when i went to click
on view submitted testimony there was
nothing there so it was conduct
and
they have corrected the categories in
the list of submissions we are in the
process now of informing them because i
just learned this morning that
apparently
while there's a list of the submitted
testimony you can't actually open
anything
so when we get through the work sessions
it is my hope that those issues will be
resolved
and once uploading is resolved there
will be the maps that come out of this
work session will be placed online
so yeah and do me a follow-up
representative lane um
are the things that we're looking at are
they over on the table is the public
able to see them now or yes they were
there were copies put over there um i'm
not sure how we're going to handle that
in the future because um
it's a significant amount of paperwork
so we're going to see what we figure out
for going forward on that but that's
what we've tried to do for today okay
thank you and just like a regular uh
work session of the house
sometimes we guess and make enough
sometimes
we don't guess correctly so
all right anybody else before we get
started
all right so
why don't we start
with bellnap only because i am afraid
that if i go out of the order on this
sheet i will become hopelessly
lost
so the first commissioner map you should
find to review
is number four
for belknap commissioners and
you should have a map with
the calculation from the program for
deviation on the back
one number
four i understand representative porter
you press the either the blue or you
push red to lock
thank you madam speaker
a little concerned as a substitute and
new to this
i've served on committee with you before
i'm not too worried okay thank you so
looking at belmont belknap county it was
not possible to create a map that kept
laconia together
so this proposed map keeps as much of
laconia
together as possible
and it puts one district
one ward 5 of
into a separate
district
so in this proposed map district 1
is now laconia wards 1
5 and 6
meredith and center harbor
district 2 would be new hampton
san berton tilton belmont and gilmanton
district 3 would be laconia ward 2
guilford alton and barnstead
the deviation between the districts is
minus 2.9 percent to 2.5 percent
or a total of 5.4 percent
and the map also keeps the existing
three county commissioners in separate
districts
so that's what this map
attempts to do
thank you all right thank you
representative porter so
um the easiest way to to look at these
quite frankly might be to look at the
numerical
listing
on the back of the map
because as
representative porter
just went through it's an easy way to
identify the communities that are in a
proposed district
and then when you look at the map side
you can see those districts in color
all right
so we have another county
commissioner map for bellnap that is the
first page of number
seven
and
i understand
that
representative mcguire would speak to
this
thank you madam chair
again this was attempting to
balance out the
the the county
and as representative porter mentioned
it's impossible to keep laconia together
it's just
the wrong size for the county i'm afraid
so this keeps together
sanborn and tilton
and all of laconia except for ward one
it keeps together
belmont gilmanton barnstead and alton
which are
adjacent and interconnected
and then
guilford meredith center harbor new
hampton and laconia ward 1.
the deviation is minus 3 to plus 3.9
and
that's
okay
okay so
committee members comments
i'm embarrassed
madam chair because i really thought i
understood all of this
when it says in the bottom caption
i understand the 2020 populations
but how can
each of these be 2012 districts
when they're different
i think that refers to the underlying
program representative mcguire uh i
don't that shows up on every single
map it does so i believe it's the
essentially county and town lines i
don't know where that came from
but the populations are the 2020.
i understand the populations but i
i for example am curious about
what the existing
structure is i know that when we went
through it when a group of people
working with me went through it
we decided to keep
an overwhelming majority of the lines
the same county to county
and so
that's why we didn't submit changes
but
we need to have us
it would be helpful i think to see what
is
if that's relevant
or
to make sure that this label
um
the label is misleading i'm sorry for
belaboring but
i
my mind isn't up to this creativity
madam chair
it's not really a matter of creativity i
incorrect
number down there and it was supposed to
be 2012. yeah i'm not i'm not really too
worried about it because i know that the
the towns correspond with the deviation
calculation representative barry
yes to that point i mean
what matters is are the populations
accurate to the 2020 census numbers and
are the town lines correct and they
appear to be
so it's something i think we just
disregard and move on i apologize for
not addressing it earlier i did notice
it on the maps that were printed out but
there was no way that i was going to be
able to change the program printout and
there was no way that i was asking staff
to go through to whiteout 2012.
representative thank you thank you very
much i understand completely okay yes
madam chair
representative porter i recognized
thank you madam chair i was just
wondering about in this map
are the county commissioners that exist
now are they still in the same districts
i don't know i've got a few people with
computers i'm sure they could look it up
representative mcguire yes i was i was
going to say that the current
commissioner districts are new hampton
belmont gilmanton and tilton
alton center harbor guilford and
meredith which is
not identical to either so
okay so
neither map corresponds to current
county commissioners i will say i've had
the opportunity to
do a couple of mapping seminars and one
of the things they tell us is that
protecting incumbency
is not something that is to be done in
mapping so
[Music]
i think it is useful to see where
current lines are but i will say at
least from what i've been told that is
one of the tenets of mapping in
redistricting
representative porter yes miss madam
chair is bellnap one of the counties
where all of the residents of the county
vote for all of the commissioners
i don't believe i don't believe so i
think that happens in stratford and i'm
not sure where else
no there's another one it has no there's
another one that does the dis that still
districts them but you you everybody
votes i'm not sure which one it is it's
not hillsboro i know that no
thank you does anybody know i should
know
okay
all right representative mcguire could
you go through the current districts
after having said we're not supposed to
pay any attention to it
um could you go through what the current
districts are again a little slower
yes ma'am
new hampton
all of laconia yes ma'am okay
okay district two barnstead
belmont
gilmanton
okay
district three alton
guilford meredith
so it's it's so it's a little all over
madam chair
representative bergeron thank you um and
i'm sure i don't know what um
your policy would be toward using
computers i think several of us have
have them
and for those that do i might just
mention that chapter 662 of the rsas
lists out all the towns in the various
districts
for for all the
county commissioners and wards and so on
so it might be handy for those with
computers to just have that i believe if
you have a copy of the bill and of
course i don't have that um
notebook with me today the bills
actually list them
as they exist currently because those
bills were taken
uh modified for the year but the actual
listings for example in the reps and all
of those are as they are currently in
executive session we'll be taking those
bills and voting on them with our
amendment so representative bergeon is
correct you can look in statute or the
bill representative barry
um yes madam chairman i just want to go
back to your original point which is
when we draw these lines
as you mentioned factoring in where the
incumbents live and what the current
lines are is not it's not something
that we've taken up as a standard in any
way and i don't believe from what you
just said it should be a standard in any
way
so i'm kind of curious why we're going
to go
through reading the current lines and
asking where the current incumbents live
when that's not something that we've
established as a standard to move
forward with in fact i i would recommend
against doing that
i
might tend to agree with you but i
believe somebody was saying that that's
something they did representative porter
yes i was just curious because the map
that i presented made that point and i
wasn't sure if it was something that
was considered that's all so it's my
ignorance and i apologize i don't think
it's ignorance it's a question everybody
has it's just from a mapping standpoint
we need i think we need to be careful
that that's not
one of the things we rely on
representative bergeron um madam chai i
would just also mention and i think this
is somewhat permissible in the
redistricting process to give
consideration to the kinds of disruption
you might cause to existing voters in
existing districts or awards or
precincts
if in for example
a redistricting would change 50 percent
of the people who are registered to
already registered to vote in one
precinct award
that that's
a significant impact that might be a
factor in the hierarchy of deciding uh
what type of redistricting to do thank
you for that comment that presumes the
base you're starting from was one that
was constitutionally accurate i would
think
and that it would remain
constitutionally accurate and i think we
know from looking at some of our maps
that might not be the case
all right it's always fun to be the
can i go home now
i know
i want to thank representative porter
for being a good sport on that
um
and while we're talking just so i'm
going through my my multiple maps so
that i can sort of label them a little
further so when we get to them anything
else on belknap county
all right belknap county commissioners
so
we've heard from representative porter
as to map four
and representative mcguire as to map
seven i'm actually calling it 7a
because we're going to have a bunch of
them
they
they both seem to have deviations
which are
am i seeing any other hands or comments
on belknap county
no okay
you sure representative maguire
shouldn't we at least look at carol and
cheshire
yeah i'm just going through the list
that i have
we're going to go through all of them
i
just so and i understand we can do it
alphabetically or not unfortunately for
all of you what i'm doing
is working off of that
map
sheet where i thought it would be useful
to go through the maps that we have two
maps for
first
so
and
coast representative turcotte why don't
you start off talking about your map for
coast county commissioners certainly
thank you madam chair good morning
everybody
presumably presuming everybody has a map
in front of them so you're going to see
pretty much the northern part of the
county
that's shown in green there is one
district
we have berlin kilkenny and jefferson as
another
and then the remainder of the county to
the south and southwest is
the third
district
on the back of that they they list all
the towns i'm not going to read them all
because a lot of these towns have zero
individuals in them
but when you get to the very end you
will see that the overall
deviation is minus 1.1 to plus 0.6 for
an overall 1.7 overall
deviation
okay
so yes indeed it becomes a little
problematic when communities have a
population for the census of zero
they need to go somewhere even with the
zero though i suppose that's arguably an
could we completely eliminate the
i'm and i'm going to defer to
representative lin for that hypothetical
question
representative
representative barry so this is a little
slightly off topic but if the community
indulge me i've always wanted to say
this in a hearing there are occasions in
coast county where an individual will
vote from
a township and they will be the only
person voting from that township and
their results are reported from that
township so their access to a secret
ballot
is not around he goes and i've always
thought it's been super awkward if they
had a neighbor and they said hey you
know tim did you vote for me he's like
oh of course i did and then joe goes to
check the results and turns out
okay
all right any any questions for
representative turcotte on
pretty close piedra i i actually want
him at the beginning of this meeting to
apologize and i'll have to go to him at
the beginning of the next meeting to
apologize again you're working on it
that's what counts
so
again this is one of the counties where
the population chefs have necessitated a
change from the current maps um so we we
have submitted a change here
the proposed map
which is map number one i guess
creates two kind of uh geographically
compact districts um one with berlin and
one with milan and one
with lancaster
jefferson northumberland and whitefield
among others
and then a larger district
mostly with with
the total deviation is 6.2 percent in
this
map
i will say and i i
there's already been some discussion
about this and um
keeping existing commissioners in
separate districts our map does not as a
not the intent of the map i guess it's a
side effect of the way it was mapped
um
i will
i guess not challenge but i i guess i
have a question about
why that isn't
something that is a good thing
i could just be my lay perspective but
it seems like allowing voters to
continue
choosing the representatives that they
currently have
rather than forcing them to choose
someone else
is a potential positive um
so i'll just throw that out there and
there's something i'm missing that's
fine again not a
goal of this map but um it is a result
of this map that i think is not the case
in the map that was
okay
i know representative smith has attended
a couple of those
[Music]
um mapping redistricting seminars does
it's an interesting question but i
suppose
we would have to then agree that
everything that's currently is terrific
is constitutional
um and there is an idea that you're not
supposed to be protecting your own
incumbency it's one of the arguments in
regards to redistricting that occurs
as to how it is to proceed so while we
may not have any commissioners sitting
here we certainly have people sitting
here that are affected by redistricting
and to start with that premise requires
us all to start with the premise that
the existing map is serving
appropriately the interests of the
electorate and
i'm not sure that that's the case or
else we wouldn't have people saying
uh things in regards to where we should
go and redistricting so i sort of like
the approach that we're starting fresh
we have a population and we have
criteria that we have that we need to
address
and we can look at all our constituents
and say whether or not you believe
you're represented is your choice
um we're we're meeting the bounds that
we have set
um it's an interesting concept anybody
else want to chime in representative
barry
yes madam chairman um
lines are for the people and not for the
politicians
representative lynn yeah i just would
say i think from as like sort of as a
constitutional matter i think you are
right representative peter in the sense
that it's not it wouldn't be
unconstitutional to do that
uh but and i think there are
you know there's case law that certainly
says that but i think the for for the
reasons that some of the other
representatives have already said
on the question of is it a good idea
that you know it is obviously
an overt political consideration to say
well we're going to try to protect
incumbents and while you may
constitutionally be able to do that if
the objective is to you know
to sort of avoid the
the uh
uh to the extent possible the political
implications then then i think that uh
what what has been suggested are very
representative lane
representative bergeron um
this is kind of related and i said kind
of related
the cities are
going to now seriously begin changing
their ward lines because city elections
are over and
there were some charter questions and so
on on the ballot this this past election
once the city's changed the award lines
that will have an impact on some of the
currently serving
state representatives
they may now be residing in a ward that
that's now in a different district so
would it be something we should be
considering when we look at our
legislation to ensure that those people
continue to serve out their terms even
if they have been bumped out of their
their awards or should we
and i'm thinking filing periods too and
maybe i'm starting to get ahead of
myself but i i think you're getting a
representative turcotte
thank you madam chair just to clarify
something representative lin said
in regards to
reps
piedra
point and that is
while
your issue might be allowed
constitutionally it's certainly not a
constitutional mandate
it's just just for clarification
representative piedra i just want to
clarify i said this already but
an objective in creating these maps
so
but i think it again in my lay opinion
if we have two maps and they're both
constitutionally permissible and i
haven't heard any reason why
one map is better than the other for
some other reason
then it seems to me that it's something
that can at least be discussed as a
factor
we may differ whether
an opinion i guess from a policy
perspective
whether it's better to just be blind in
drawing maps or whether
it's better to allow
like i said a voter to continue voting
for a representative that they like
rather than being forced to make another
choice i think there's
reasonable policy disagreement there's
no right or wrong
in that but i just wanted to clarify not
the objective of this map
thank you representative and i will just
note that as he was speaking i was
thinking of the glories of youth
because there was a couple of
presumptions in that that current
representatives were of any type we're
going to be able to keep running and
running and running
and these maps are in fact one of the
goals of these maps i hope for everybody
is to draw fair maps for representation
for the people over the next 10 years so
i'm feeling very optimistic after that
statement representative barry
yes to representative bergeron's point
um so it's it's my understanding that
when we have an election in a district
you you cover that region until the next
election is certified or enacted right
when you know we get elected on november
and we all get sworn into december right
so you represent even if the district
even if the underlying district is
changing you represent those individual
those people until
the next election is
certified or enacted whatever we want to
call it
thank you
representative smith
thank you very much
went to look to representative smith a
few
a few
exchanges ago i naturally looked to your
right thinking you were
thinking of the vice chair of this
committee
who i see is not present today so i'm
the only smith present and from now on i
understand that
um at least just for the day
um
but he will be here shortly so confusion
can resume oh dear me
well that's all right um i i do want to
say that um
i uh
i agree with with your point madam chair
this situation that we're trying to go
through in a very compact period of time
is complicated enough and
i would hope that we focus our
discussion
only on
the very core issues in terms of what is
constitutional
what is required
by federal and state law
and
not
include in our discussion issues which
might be interesting if we were
at the end of the day and sharing a cup
of tea
but are not
absolutely relevant
and essential to our decisions here
i think the the fewer of those um
outlying issues that
get raised the easier it will be
one hopes to find a way that all members
of this committee will be able to agree
on the best districts
representative wilhelm so far i'm living
longer and we have an easy path so if
you keep this up we're doing good
thank you madam chair
uh
i will just say i i do enjoy hearing uh
because criteria was not necessarily
agreed upon by the entire committee i do
really appreciate hearing
uh what
members took into consideration as they
were drawing the map so i do hope that
that continues not necessarily the
the information that would be shared
over a cup of tea i agree um but i think
the criteria is important and i think uh
members of the public have have asked
for specific criteria to be used so that
i i i hope that we don't lose that as
part of this conversation
thank you
all right believe it or not on my
meeting schedule we're still on coast
commissioners
any comments further comments on the
coast commissioner maps that we've been
all right i'm not seeing any so we're
going to move on to merrimack county
we have
two maps to consider for merrimack
county
number two
from representative lane and in the
package labeled number seven it's
down there it would be
if you're doing alphabetizing g
so representative lane if you'd be kind
enough to start with your proposed map
thank you madam chair
[Music]
merrimack county needed really small
changes to meet the population deviation
requirements the only change in our pro
proposed map
makes it um is moving willmont from
existing district three to district two
and with that change the deviation
between the districts is negative two
point seven percent to two point nine
percent for a total of five point six
percent
so
they gave me the easy one
so that's
that's it
any questions comments on
map labeled number two merrimack
commissioners
okay i'm not seeing any
merrimack
from the seven stack representative
mcguire
my plan on this was to keep the cities
together
and
which as is the current practice in
commissioner districts
uh concord has almost 13 reps
so i matched it with bow which
which is less than 500 off a perfect
uh one third of the county
rather than basquin and what and webster
which is further off
and then i
start started there trying to equalize
and you'll notice that the deviation is
0.9
for both of district 2 and district 3.
so
the total deviation is 2.7 percent
if you
okay
questions
for representative mcguire comments
on the merrimack commissioner map in the
stack number seven representative porter
thank you madam chair um representative
are there um communities of interest
i say i don't know this information but
it looks like
there might not be so many communities
of interest between pittsfield and
henniker
but yet that would all be one district
that's correct there's also no community
of interest between pittsfield and say
hill
communities of interest representative
porter is not a standard that has been
adopted by the committee nor even really
discussed in death when you're talking a
third of the county representative
porter you've got
you it's it's
you you're going to have
hanaker and pittsfield are different no
question about it but so are newberry
and chichester
you've got to split the
once you say
concord sitting in the middle with
almost a third of the population you
then just divide it into contiguous
equal population groups
they're not
um
it's just population numbers you go
okay
merrimack
the last county commissioner that i have
received
two maps for
so we're going to go
now to packet seven
and
work our way through the maps that we
have not already discussed
and the first one would be carol
and i'm going to recognize
thank you madam chair
hello again everybody uh carroll county
again if you have it in front of you uh
pretty much the northern part of the
part that seems to come down a little
bit from that is the addition of
sandwich
you have a
central part of the county
the green as you see on your sheets
and then along the eastern
part of the county down
to the base
this has a total all total overall
deviation of minus 3 to
positive 2.6 for 5.8
overall
okay
comments on the carol
commissioner
map
i actually started to think why do we
have three all over the place
how did that happen but that's a
discussion for another day
representative wayne
thank you i just wanted to point out
that
we did not submit
no one submitted one on these counties
because the
population change was not significant in
any of these counties so felt that it
was appropriate to keep them as they
were
since the deviations all matched and it
seemed and we looked at the different
factors and decided not to submit them
so if we need to submit the existing
ones i think that would probably make it
a lot easier for people to understand
what the proposal is okay
because i have no idea
and i think it would be harder for
members of the public to understand what
proposed changes
because i know in my community if you
asked people what commissioner's
district they were in they would not
most of the people would not be able to
tell you right thank you
which should give you great faith that
all right so
then the next one i believe is cheshire
which the other representative smith was
going to speak to
representative turkite you want to speak
again it looks like
representative representative steve
smith has kept all of keene together
added roxbury and marlborough on to it
to make it a central district
then we have a northern northwest to
southwest district in green and a
pretty solid
uniform district in the southwest south
southwest corner of the county
the deviation
is minus 3.5 to 4 for a total of 7.5
overall
and as i did not
do this map i can't speak to the thought
process that went into it
representative lane i'm going to let you
make the same comment i'm assuming on
this
yes i'll just make it for all of them
for one time so you don't need to well i
i actually don't think it's a bad idea
for you to just summarize it for each
because people may be watching and not
be watching for the whole thing or
coming in and out
um
okay
so do you want me to yeah why don't you
just quickly you can you know we did not
feel because there were in these seven
counties the population deviation didn't
i mean the population didn't change that
much so it was not necessary to
reallocate and redo the existing
okay
all right so that cheshire any comments
on cheshire
anybody have any idea what the current
district is in cheshire
without looking it up madam chair i've
got it on at the computer here okay
for cheshire district number one is
chesterfield hinsdale surrey swansea
walpole westmoreland and winchester
which is the western edge basically
district two
marlboro roxbury and keene
so that's the same
right district three alstead dublin
fitzwilliam gilsum harrisville jeffrey
marlow nelson
richmond bridge stoddard sullivan and
troy
okay
thank you
all right moving on
the next one i believe would be grafton
that we have not spoken of
i've marked that as 7e representative
thank you madam chair again we start by
keeping the
only only city together that is lebanon
added two adjacent towns
and then
split the rest of the
county by population
northern
and southeast and the deviation is 1.4
percent
okay
representative lane
sorry about that
but i think it's messy again we did not
submit a map because uh the population
did not change that much in this county
and felt that the current deviations
worked um i will also add that we will
be submitting
seven new maps
i'm not sure when lindsay if you're
listening i know you're very excited to
hear that representative lane you're
fortunate you only need six because
stratfor county doesn't have districts
madam chair i i think representative
turcotte and i um would feel very
strongly that we wouldn't want stratfor
county not to be included as one of the
10 counties
thank you
in that case we can agree on on one map
absolutely actually i sort of want to
have two maps and start a discussion on
them and then see how long it takes for
people to figure out they're actually
all right
the next one i
believe we have not discussed is
thank you madam chair i didn't really
work on this but i don't know why did is
there anybody else that would prefer to
speak to hillsborough
representative barry do you want to do
do you want to you're a rep from it from
the hillsborough district very proudly
from hillsborough okay thank you um i
believe
county commissioner has not been a focus
of mine but i believe this is the same
as it currently is i'm not that we're
using that as a standard in any way um
but this uh
this keeps manchester bedford and new
boston together
um it keeps uh south
see i've got my east and west mixed up
for a second southeast hillsborough
county together with nashua litchfield
hudson and pelham
and then the rest of hillsborough county
is all in one district
and excuse me madam chairman supposed to
read the pub supposed to read the
deviations
um but it's only the page here we go
3.9 that we have a three point a
negative 3.9 to a negative 1.1 or a 2.8
percent deviation overall
okay
do you want me to make the same comment
madam chair
yeah do you know whether hillsborough
do you know what hillsborough looks like
now i'm sort of curious i was just
eyeballing it against the list in the um
in the statute that
represented bergeron and quickly looking
it looks like it is the same so we might
actually have stratford and hillsborough
to agree upon
excellent
okay
the next one i believe
that we should discuss would be
uh thank you madam chair that was one
that i oh no i'm sorry representative
barry sorry i have too many crib sheets
up here
excuse me yes madam chairman um so this
is a um
a north middle and south district so you
have the southern part of rockingham
county is in one district
the middle part of the county going
north to south is in one district and
the northernmost part of the county is
in one district and it has a deviation
of
drum roll please
uh a deviation of negative 3 to negative
okay comments on this
representative wilhelm thank you madam
chair just to clarify this is map 7h is
that right that's what i come up with
the next one that i have
we're going to do this just because it's
going to be so fun stratford
representative
thank you yeah representative wilhelm
sorry i just wanted to
back to rockingham yeah back to
rockingham thank you thanks
uh
all of portsmouth is together
it may not be in the picture but it's
all together
do you know why it didn't print out on
the on the town list uh i will find out
and come back
all right maybe we'll have that subject
thank you madam chair i didn't hear if
representative elaine said that we would
be submitting him
i was going to let somebody else do it
okay well i'm from rockingham so why
don't i
there you go
madam chair uh um i'll be submitting a
map that looks uh like the current
breakup of the county um commissioner
districts in the county of rockingham
thank you
all right now drum roll stratford
thank you madam chair
i'd like to present the stratford county
commissioners map
i think this will be the cleanest of
them all we have a
zero percent deviation
madam chairman i'd like to applaud
representative turcotte's presentation
if only that was it and we could all go
home
and then
just in time
the last county commissioner map that
we're taking a look at is
and your multi-purpose chair
is now going to recognize representative
steve smith to discuss
the
thank you madam chair
uh not a huge change i don't think so
one of the challenges we had was that uh
clermont lost some population and if you
look at the map you have claremont and
newport two relatively large
municipalities
like a great big wall down the middle of
the county so
this is what we came up with there are
not a lot of ways to do it
claremont ward one and three are with
newport
then pretty much the northern towns are
another district the southern the other
district
and we come out with a total 8.7
deviation
this seems to make sense
we've got the larger municipalities
together and then the
the rural ones that may have a different
point of view on things particularly on
county allocations grouped together so i
representative smith we're not
necessarily using it as a criteria but
it would appear that some people thought
the current districts worked so another
map was not submitted we will be getting
another map to show the current district
would you happen to know what the
no not off the top of my head okay um
nope then don't go there if it's not
right we don't want to hear it i can't
tell you what i do know for uh for sure
though is that it is similar in that uh
most of claremont is in one and then the
smaller rural towns are in the others so
the concept is the same
representative porter yeah just out of
curiosity madam chair
because i'm new to this i'm looking at
claremont ward 2 having
4316 people
and then i'm looking at sunapee and
goshen
together which is pretty close to that
and i'm wondering why the decision was
made to go to split up claremont where
we've been keeping cities together
um and and not
going the other direction i'm just
curious i'd like to know what the
thinking was there
thanks
go ahead it's representative smith if
you want to respond yeah i'm not sure
what you're getting you're suggesting
that sunapee and goshen be added to
newport
no that uh claremont ward 2 be included
with cl the rest of claremont
and matt goshen and sunapee would be in
that green
uh district rather than in the blue
so
total these two
i would have to do the math on that okay
so okay i'm just curious
yeah
yeah did it a while ago when it's the uh
the arithmetic always gets you by just
that much you know i don't know thank
you
other questions
on this map representative lane i don't
want to miss my last chance so
we did not submit a map on this because
of the
population did not change all that much
and the existing
deviations were appropriate and the
existing one keeps claremont together
with cornish to answer representative
okay
other questions or comments any other
questions or comments on commissioner
maps
okay
now that i have my maps all completely
we're going to go to representative
district
maps
and the first one we're going to discuss
is
merrimack
there should be a merrimack in packet
number
six
and
a merrimack
number
10.
okay this is where your eyeballing
skills are really going to have to come
merrimack county we sort of had a dry
run of merrimack county at our last work
session so i'm going to ask
representative mcguire to again do us
the favor and lead off on going through
proposed representative district maps
thank you madam chair
this is
very similar to what i presented a
couple of weeks ago i did listen to the
comments and make a couple of tweaks
pembrom pembroke gets its own standalone
district
epsom gets its own district plus a float
and i also i also split the new london
district in half so that it's
it's two two town districts instead of
and that's
excuse me the deviation is
just under 10 percent on
9.2
okay you rep the last town you
referenced i'm having a hard time coming
up with here
you talked about pembroke you kept its
own
epson you kept its own and added a float
and what was the last comment you made i
split the new london district from four
uh
from a four town three rep district to
two two
okay questions for representative
the colors are pretty but with the
different multi-town districts and
floats it's still hard to follow
yes some of the floats are a little
larger than i would like
i'll particularly mention my district
but that's
but it
it's
the numbers come out very nicely
and with
all these odd-sized towns that's about
anything else for representative mcguire
on this map
it's one of the tenets of running a good
meeting hand everybody a lot of paper it
all right
i understand we have another map number
10 for merrimack county representative
lane
thank you madam chair
the proposed map
includes 32 total districts 25 base and
7 floaterial
with a total of 45 seats
the map keeps concord completely
separate from other towns
in a base and floaterial districts
which it was it which is not in the
existing map
the map also increases the number of
towns with their own base districts from
four to nine
and the total deviation for the proposed
map is 8.8 percent
do you want me to run through the
districts
or
give people time
so
let me people are still sort of looking
here okay
i was just thinking that representative
bergeron brought in crayons to help mark
up
and that i don't think his crayon box is
big enough for what i would like to do
on this which would be to color code
each town from one to the other
right
and that box has long been decimated i'm
pretty sure i don't have all those
all right representative lane if you
wanted to go into more detail
do you want me to go through the list
madam chair i mean it's written in paper
and okay i i mean i can alright i mean
one of the reasons we're doing okay so
let's just review what we're talking
about doing we have one or two maps for
every commissioner or
and two maps so far for every rep
district it is the intent to go to the
public input session with both maps next
week so there is no why the agenda
indicated something as to going forward
in a vote but it is the chair's intent
that both maps be brought forward um and
unless somebody makes a motion to do
something differently that's what we're
going to do and i don't really see the
need for a vote so
keep that in mind
as we go forward that doesn't preclude
discussion on other maps certainly but
as far as what would be posted online
and for the discussion next week at the
work session we're going to work off the
it's bad enough when you're working on
one map at a time that when you get all
of them well i just felt like everybody
can read probably absolutely
i would point out that one of the
factors that we did look at was some
communities of interest and i know
that's not a
factor that we've adopted but we did try
to look at that as well
in in
in the merrimack map it's not perfect
and if anybody has suggestions great but
okay
any questions on either of the merrimack
maps
and i i think maybe tomorrow what we'll
do is we'll have a follow-up first thing
about whether there are people who have
looked at stuff from today and there's
questions to go through tomorrow so
even though you've talked about maybe a
map you worked on today keep in mind
that i think that if members have
questions or want to follow up on
something
we should do that also tomorrow so
all right if i don't see anything else
from a member i'm not seeing any hands
or hearing any voices on merrimack let's
move to bellnap
belknap
and it is the second map
in
as to the representative meant for
belknap why don't we go to
representative turcotte first please
thank you madam chair
uh belknap county uh for those you have
very similar to what exists now the some
of the towns down in the southwest
corner had significant
uh or i shouldn't say significant
population changes but enough to make
some of the existing
districts
outside of the constitutional one man
one vote limit
representative turcotte is your mic on i
do
okay
you want me closer there we go sorry
sorry christine i haven't been looking
at you
the county itself ends up with six
districts no
floats
the deviation on the entire county is
minus 0.78 to 4.62 for overall deviation
of only 5.4
anybody who has worked on some of these
smaller counties such as belknap
with small populations and then
when if you have your
allocation
map or spreadsheet in front of you you
know that
belknap was going to get 18.49
reps which makes a small county with
small populations a very difficult
county to
do
but we were able to keep it
very similar to what we have today
laconia is all together
with the exception of laconia iv which
is with uh belmont as it currently is
today
uh the only really major major change as
i said was down in the southeast corner
we
paired up alton with barnstead and
gilmington with belmont other than that
the county remains very very similar to
thank you
and i will just point out looking at
both maps i have the same color at the
sort of the top of the county and the
bottom of the county on each map so
there you go
so this is bellnap
county
representative wilhelm do you want to
talk about belknap county that will be
map that's numbered eight
i would thank you madam chair
uh
my map is a little bit different uh the
proposed house map for belknap county
includes eight total districts so seven
base one floaterial
total of 18 seats
and
you know district one it's the same as
the existing district
two
meredith gets its own district of two
seats currently meredith's paired with
guilford
um only connected through the lake
district three
is samberton and tilton
so sambert and tilton currently share a
district uh but with two seats
fluterial was necessary to balance the
populations
with this district in belmont
sanberton and tilton they also
share a community of interest which is
something that i thought about with this
map
they both send high schoolers to
uh district four
belmont's a single seat district
belmont currently has its own district
of two members but a float's necessary
to balance the populations of samberton
and tilton
district five is laconia awards one
through five it's four seats
wasn't possible to keep the city of
laconia completely intact
this proposed map keeps five wards in
laconia together in a four-seat base
district and one word in another
district
district six is guilford gilmanton
laconia ward six total of four seats
guilford and gillington send their high
schoolers to guilford high school so
that made sense as a community of
interest
district 7 alton and barnstead three
seats
both alton and barnstead send their high
schoolers to prospect mountain high
school
uh district eight is belmont samerton
and tilton two-seat floaterial
just to balance the populations there
that's why the float was necessary
between the two underlying districts
and total deviation for this proposed
map including both base influential is
thanks
thank you
questions
comments on belmar representative
was that the only place that meredith
and guilford
touched each other was in the middle of
lake winnipesaukee
and everyone who testified
pleaded with us to separate
the two so that they could
so that the representatives could more
meaningfully represent their districts
and i am
as i was pleased when i first saw this
map to see that in fact guilford and
meredith have been separated
wouldn't couldn't one argue that
being co-a butters to the largest
lake mass in new hampshire creates a
huge
common interest between your communities
and that therefore
if that is the jointer point it is the
most important
point
do we have a district with something
from the isles of shoals
representative barry uh two things i'm
number one to uh representative marjorie
smith representative marjorie smith's uh
point uh we actually fought a war over
the isles of shields called the maine
lobster wars um go look it up um and
number two to her point about the maps
um what we did here about meredith we
did also hear
a lot of testimony about the use of
floaterials
okay
other questions or comments
people were paying attention at those
i expected this to go into this
afternoon folks but i think at this
point my intent is to go through these
and we're going to break for the day and
come back tomorrow morning we'll start
off
um
seeing sort of recapping what we did
today and and clarifying what's
happened and then we'll go into the
remainder rep districts in the cd
districts
yep no i'm just sort of letting
everybody know because i just looked at
my watch and
time flies when you're having fun but
not as much
representative wilhelm madam chair thank
you i saw on the agenda other
submissions i'm curious what those are
and if there there are any it's the
mapathon
well you you received something from
mapathon that was passed out
um at the beginning of the meeting but
this is a work session so if somebody
has something i'm leaving it open if
somebody has some a member of the
committee has something else that they
want to talk about they certainly are
free to do so
but the underlying purpose so you're
clear is that two maps will go to the
public input session as being the
products of this committee
so if you want it to be something other
than what's coming
as i guess at this point i can say one
side of the table or the other there's
going to have to be a vote because my
intent would be
that the
public input sessions
in the first instance be driven by
whatever as
a committee we have presented with the
opportunity for you all to point out
during these meetings or the public at
the public input session
other maps that have been presented and
i know that
um everybody sort of has gotten their
maps done
very recently so i'm aware that not
everybody has all discussion points
ready on everything
so if some if you want to bring up
something else
we certainly can do it
all right we're going to move on to
rockingham
and rockingham
representative simpson you want to kick
this off
for rockingham
sure i'd be happy to
um
so
as you know i was not a substitute in
the last meeting so apologies if the way
i do this is um
is too
detailed and laborious but i was
planning to go up go through each
district that's fine as quickly okay
great thank you rockingham is sort of a
tough district so it is right and it's
got a lot of towns um
so i appreciate that
so um
our guiding principles here are that
each town gets its own representative as
often as possible
and that the
districts be as small as possible which
also helps minimize barriers for
access to running for office
and then
we prioritize small single seat
districts rather than the large
multi-member districts which we do have
a number of um
in
in rockingham
so
i'm going to hold up my map
i'm starting up here in the top uh
northern corner
so district one um
would be deerfield northwood and
nottingham
all together receiving three seats
and then district 2 right to the south
is auburn and candia
both towns do send high schoolers to
pinkerton
and they would have two seats together
raymond then is next door and would have
three seats that's the same as the
existing district londonderry likewise
is the same as the existing districts
seven seats
dairy 10 seats that's what is happening
now
windham also has three seats which is
the same as the existing district
then salem
right in the far south has nine seats
which is like the existing district
now i'm jumping up over to
kind of the middle
the pink up here epping
has two seats which is the same as the
existing district
and
in this map brentwood fremont and
chester
would be grouped together with four
seats
now sandown this little purple one in
here
it would have two seats on its own this
is a new town that would receive its own
state representatives
danville right next door in orange is
the same as the existing district they
have one seat
hampstead would have two seats this
would be a new town that would get its
own state representatives
atkinson likewise would have two seats
it would be a new town having its own
base district
that's right there
um
kingston and plaistow
in the light green there
would get four seats together
and then new fields in newmarket
jumping up to the north in that dark
pink
they would have their own three seats as
they do currently
exeter would have four seats as it
currently does
stratum would have two seats as it
then east kingston kensington newton and
southampton
and blue at the south
would each have or would all have three
seats together
hampton falls and seabrook
would be the same existing district with
three seats
they do both send high schoolers to win
a
cunnit district 20 next door which would
be hampton
and northampton
in green
they also send high schoolers to win a
connect and would have six seats
together
now up here to um the yellow piece is
rye and newcastle which are an existing
district now with two seats
greenland and newington and brown
would have one seat that's the same as
the existing district
and each of the portsmouth wards would
have one seat that's the same as what is
and then in rockingham there are a
number of flow cereals
so
district 28 would be a floaterial
composed of districts one and two
so this is kind of a big floaterial
in the north
corn the north west corner
um
do you see that it's all in blue light
and dark blue together that would be one
fluterial
district 29 would be another floaterial
this would be districts four and six
which i do not have these all memorized
would be londonderry and windham
down there in the south
right
there and then
district 30 would be a floaterial of
districts 11 and 12 which would be
danville and hampstead which are right
here in the middle
district 31 would be um a one-seat flow
terial
with districts 15 through 17 it's the
same as the existing district
which would be
newfields newmarket exeter and stratum
three of those four towns send high
schoolers to exeter
high school
and then finally
district 32 would be a two seat flow
terial
composed of districts 22 to 27
which would be portsmouth wards plus
greenland and newington
and all of those um
do send high schoolers to portsmouth
high school
so i appreciate your patience with that
and the total deviation for this map is
on the back
and it's a 9.98
overall
maybe we need to add cross hatching
oh
yeah have those solid lines around them
which makes it a little bit easier but
yeah no they're there but yeah
you have to have your glasses on for
sure
any questions or comments on this before
i'm not seeing any so representative
thank you madam chair
rockingham
um
we'll just start out by saying we
were able to get 38 districts out of the
the county
uh with nine floats um
as always try to maximize our our
districts in each county it doesn't
always work but
when you have a big county like
rockingham it's a little bit easier i'd
like to point out a couple commonalities
um which is kind of interesting the
upper left-hand uh northwest corner
uh we
representative simpson's map and mine
both have a float with the identical 24
684 we just pair our towns slightly
differently
then i would also like to note that
the east
part of the county from basically
stratum
to the east uh is going to be very
familiar to
the folks who gave us the packet this
morning so they will enjoy that so a
little commonality there i am not going
to go through and read all of them there
are 38 districts they're all listed on
the back
[Music]
and we do end up with
nine floats
the
total deviation on ours goes from minus
4.93 to positive 4.86 9.8 overall
thank you madam chief
thank you questions for representative
turcotte
all right i'm not seeing any
for us to parse this but
newcastle
and
newington
newcastle and uh newington do not
um you'll so it's just going through
the portsmouth you need those two
portsmouth wards to do that that's
correct
if you look on the uh the next page
after
excuse me the map itself it'll it lays
out the districts yeah if you go there
and you'll see
so you split off two portsmouth wards
that's correct with newcastle
and as i noted before you would find
that
the gentleman's maps in the back to the
exact same thing it
actually is a very
very solid
solid way to do it thank you
okay
all right so the last
representative map we have scheduled for
today is
coast
again in
packet six that should be the first map
you have
and packet number nine representative
thank you madam chair a very simple
uh explanation on this uh six districts
we
did uh absolutely zero floats
um we didn't uh
see the need for it by adding a float
just for the sake of having it
um you'll note
the districts they're there right for
you to see in the uh in the different
colors
uh one note that i didn't mention while
we do we were doing the
uh
county commissioners is that
i was able to
mirror to to the biggest extent possible
the county commissioners
and the
rep map
so you'll note that the
district in the middle berlin kilkenny
and jefferson mirror exactly the
commissioners
and then the northern part of the county
and southern pound of the county were
mirrors not quite as much but very
similarly so this one again six
districts no floats uh overall deviation
8.68
and uh please do not ask me to read all
the towns
thank you madam chair representative
barry i just want to ask representative
turcotte a question by mirror the
county commissioners maps you mean the
proposed ones not the current
that's
correct other questions for
okay i'm not seeing any so we're going
to move on to the coast map it's
numbered
representative piedra thank you madam
chair
our map appears very similar to the map
just presented by representative
turcotte
i'll also note that the map we are
submitting
i believe is identical to the map
submitted by the good folks at the
mapathon
we do include a float in our map because
berlin is the only municipality that is
entitled to its own district
um in the county and so we did preserve
that
um and in order to do that we did create
a float
for the third seat in that area
but otherwise the map is very similar to
okay
all right questions or comments on
anything that we've had so far today
okay you just had referenced a
map-a-thon map you have that
in front of you as a packet
anybody have an update on the website as
to whether or not it looks
anybody can you can read it yet i'm
christina
pardon me
and you can read it now all right so i'm
assuming that uploading can now
hopefully it functions in all aspects
i'll be around and hear and take a look
to make sure that it can so uh members
you know you can get back on that site
now it's been down for a couple of days
to see it and
um you were actually emailed over the
weekend
um
as a member of the committee this link
to the site so if you don't want to go
through the new hampshire court site you
can get to it
through that email that has the direct
link to the site as compared to it being
representative
are you back tomorrow for somebody else
i thought it was for representative
okay correct yep all right i had a few
substitutions and i just wasn't i'm my
brain isn't focused too much on tomorrow
yet
all right so we need another packet
okay
representative welcome
thank you madam chair maps that were
submitted today by members when will
those be made available to the public um
i'm not sure i'm going to have to deal
all right so we need another map set for
okay
if
people don't have anything else for
today
we will adjourn until 10 o'clock
tomorrow
so thank you very much everybody thank
you for your attentiveness
you